Pennywise is returning, and the Losers' Club
might not like it, but film critics are pretty
psyched.
It: Chapter Two has been screened for professional
reviewers, and most are in agreement that
the flick is a worthy follow-up to 2017's
smash hit It: Chapter One, and that together,
the two movies represent one of the better
Stephen King adaptations ever put to film.
Of course, given some of the King adaptations
over the years, that's not a particularly
high bar.
King's 1986 novel It tells the story of a
group of outcast youths who must confront
the evil plaguing their small town of Derry,
Maine, one which appears most often in the
guise of Pennywise, the Dancing Clown.
During a battle in the sewers below the streets
of Derry, the "Losers' Club" manages to severely
wound It and drive It back into hibernation,
but they fail to finish the job.
When It returns over a quarter century later,
It's all too eager for a rematch with the
now-adult Losers, and it's got a couple new
tricks up its sleeve.
"At this point, anything is possible, so yes:
pies, seltzer bottles, balloon animals...be
alert."
Bill Skarsgård was praised far and wide for
his performance as Pennywise in Chapter One,
and that trend continued with the second installment,
with many critics noting that director Andy
Muschietti's decision to give Pennywise less
screen time actually served to make him even
scarier.
Brian Truitt of USA Today wrote:
"Andy Muschietti deploys Pennywise sparingly;
it's a smart decision, because it makes the
villain's appearances special, and Skarsgård
finds new ways to totally freak you out, even
in a surprisingly human fashion."
Katie Smith-Wong of Flick Feast agreed, praising
the performances of the entire cast while
singling out Skarsgård in particular:
"Overall, It: Chapter Two reminds audiences
that horror film sequels can be good, with
Skarsgård reinforcing Pennywise's position
as the scariest clown ever."
The entire cast was on the receiving end of
plenty of critical kudos, but none quite so
much as Bill Hader, the Saturday Night Live
vet who has proven adept at folding a little
darkness into his hilarious persona with his
HBO series Barry.
Bill Goodykoontz's review in Arizona Republic
stated:
"Everyone in the cast is good, [James] Ransone
as the hypochondriac Eddie, who never ceases
complaining, is welcome comic relief.
But Hader rises above the rest.
If you've seen Barry… [then] you know he
has no problem blending comedy and drama.
In this case, he adds horror to the mix, and
he's just as good at that, too."
But with a novel as thematically dense and
challenging as the source material, a crackerjack
cast will get you nowhere without an expertly
crafted script and assured direction, and
fortunately, Muschietti and screenwriter Gary
Dauberman came through.
Digital Spy's Ian Sandwell wrote the movie
might make anyone fear clowns:
"Muschietti has managed to craft a series
of chilling set pieces designed to give everyone
a touch of coulrophobia.
While there's nothing in the sequel that a
die-hard horror fan won't have seen before,
the set pieces are so effectively done that
they'll have an impact regardless."
Alex Godrey of Empire also gushed over the
dedication to craft apparent throughout the
sequel, saying:
"A psychologically merciless sequel, everything
here is as it should be: deeper, scarier,
funnier.
Muschietti in particular has stepped up, skilfully
guiding us through a rollicking funhouse.
It is obscenely entertaining."
Of course, not every film can please every
critic, and even some of It: Chapter Two's
positive reviews said that it may have been
a bit of a letdown from the first film.
The film's beefy run time at just under three
hours was a sticking point for some reviewers,
including Entertainment Weekly's Leah Greenblatt,
who wrote:
"The main problem with Chapter Two is that
it goes on, and on, for so very long.
If brevity is not necessarily the soul of
a good scare, it would certainly serve a story
that sends in the clowns, and then lets them
just stay there, leering and lurking and chewing
through scene after scene, until the there's
nothing left to do but laugh, or leave."
Still others, like A.V.
Club's Katie Rife, faulted the flick for its
perceived failure to deliver the one thing
that would have made up for having your butt
glued to theater seat for the better part
of three hours: actual scares.
"The film isn't an abject failure by any means;
it has some funny jokes, a couple of really
good performances, impressive creature and
set design, and pleasing cinematography.
But when it comes down to it, It: Chapter
Two just isn't all that scary."
The flick's naysayers, though, were firmly
in the minority camp, and by most accounts,
Muschietti and his cast and crew have stepped
up to deliver a thrilling one-two punch, a
fitting take on what many fans consider to
be King's greatest work.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.